SEASON.
PUSHING HIS BID FOR OLYMPIC
CKS
UP HIS 400TH WIN IN THAT GAME.
RADDYSH PARKED IN FRONT.
AN.
FOR STAM
HEDMAN TO PALAT.
DON'T SEE THAT VERY OFTEN IN 10.
VICTOR HEDMAN END UP HITTING THE
POST CLOSE, BUT SERGACHEV.
OFF THE SKATE WIDE.
MAROON WITH A SHOT.
THAT'S KNOCKED AWAY.
STAMKOS.
>> WE FOUND A WAY TO MAKE COKE
ZERO SUGAR MORE DELICIOUS.. YOU
GETTING FROM RILEY NASH.
AROUND.
A STRONG POWER MOVE BY BRADY
TKACHUK TO THE NET. BROUGHT OVE
FROM COLORADO AS A FRE TEAM CAN.
THAT'S PART OF THE EVOLUTION OF
.
AND A BEAUTIFUL PASS BY
BATHERSON THAT PUTS IT ON A KEY.
RADDYSH AND KILLORN HAVING
ORRIS.
THAT TOP LINE GETTING BELLEMARE
PERRY. HOLDEN WORKS IN.
TKACHUK COMES ON.
BROWN.
7.
2 MINUTE MINOR FOR HOOKING.THER.
A STOP ONY BY TKACHUK.
AND NORRIS BACK THE OTHER WAY
.
BACKGH
THE SEAM.
AND THIS IS
WELL.O THE LIG
BUT TWO SOLID POWER PLAY LOOKS..
PALAT WITH IT.
HAT TRICK
AND HIS 11th OF THE SEASON.
TRIED TO GET IT BY